قصه ما شكلها راح تنتهي الثنائي موجودين
حاليا في نيويورك
في نيويورك حصلت على جائزه واعطت خطا
والهنا ما في دراما صارت بعد ما خلصوا
الحفل وطلعوا
في بيان على لسان المتحدث باسمهم بيقول
انهم تعرضوا لمطارده كادت ان تكون كارثيه
من مصورين
استمرت ساعتين وشارك فيها مصورين بسته
سيارات وعلى دراجات وانهم كانوا عدوانيين
وبيسوقوا بطريقه خطره جدا وقطعوا اشارات
حمراء ومشيوا عكس السير في شوارع اتجاه
واحد وعرضوا او وعرضوا وهاري ووالدتها
اللي كانت معاهم للخطر ولكن ما اصيبوا
باذى
المعلومات بعدين كشفت انه هاري وميجين
كانوا طالعين من الحفل فعلا وركبوا سياره
سوداء مضلله ولمن شافوا المصورين
بيتسابقوا ويصوروهم نزلوا من السياره
واخذوا تكسي علشان يتوهوا المصورين اللي
ما يبغوهم يستدلوا على مكان اقامتهم في
منزل احد اصدقائهم وفعلا في النهايه نجحوا
في انهم يتوهوهم طبعا خبر مثل هذا اكيد
راح يقلب الدنيا خاصه وان كلنا بنتذكر
طريقه وفاه والده هاري الاميره ديانا في
حادث في باريس تسبب في مصورين باباراتي او
على الاقل هذه هي الروايه الرسميه
المعتمده ولكن فجاه بدات تطلع اصوات تكذب
الثنائي وتنتقدهم فالناس صارت تقول ايش
معنى هم يعني من كل العيله المالكه اللي
بيصير معاهم كذب والناس ثانيه قالت كيف
مطارده سريعه وفي شوارع نيويورك اللي
معروفه بالازدحام الشديد ومن بين هذول
حاكم نيويورك نفسه اللي انسال على الموضوع
في مؤتمر صحفي
مثل ما شفتوا حاكم نيويورك قال يعني صعب
نصدق انهم كانوا ساعتين في مطارده بس على
العموم حيحققوا في الموضوع والتحقيقات هذه
على فكره بحسب الشرطه راح تشوف المواد
اللي تصورت وتشوف كاميرات المراقبه في
الشوارع والشرطه قالت انه هذا التحقيق ما
طلبوا هاري اوميجا موضوع مين طلب التحقيق
كان مسار كلام خاصه وانه الامير ان شاف في
بعض الصور بيصور اللي بيحصل معاهم في
تلفونه او عن طريق تليفونه الشخصي رد اخر
طلع كمان كان من احد اكبر شركات التصوير
في امريكا وهي شركه باك جريد اللي طلعت او
طلعت بيان قالت فيه انه اربع مصورين
بيتعاملوا معاها زودوها بالصور وانهم
كانوا في الواقع وانه ثلاثه منهم كانوا في
سيارات وواحد في دراجه وانهم كانوا بيغطوا
زياره الثنائي لنيويورك وقالت انهم ما
كانوا قاصدين اي ضرر للثنائي وكل ادواتهم
كانت كاميراتهم وقالت انهم دائما بيغطوا
احداث او اخبار متعلقه بشخصيات عامه وانهم
مهنيين ومتدربين كويس والمفاجاه الاكبر
كانت لمن طلع سواق التاكسي نفسه اللي كان
سايق في هاري اوميجا في مقابلات عديده مع
عده صحف ووسائل الاعلام وقال انه مشاعر في
اي لحظه انه في اي خطر وانه الكلام اللي
قالوا مبالغ فيه
[موسيقى]